[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning you're
looking at images from the memorial at
ground zero in new york this morning
kobe 19 of course has changed many
commemorations on this
19th anniversary of the 911 terror
attacks but it has not changed the depth
of feeling back in 2001
al qaeda terrorists hijacked four
passenger jets crashing
three into buildings here in new york
and at the pentagon
the fourth of course went down in rural
pennsylvania shanksville nearly 3 000
americans were killed that day
and a decade later american commandos
hunted down 911 mastermind osama bin
laden at his hideout in pakistan
now only on cbs this morning we are
learning the inside story
of one of the mission's best kept
secrets senior investigative
correspondent catherine herridge is at
the pentagon for us
catherine good morning to you tony good
morning once the intelligence came
together one of the final steps was
building a physical replica of the
compound
so the policy makers and military
planners could visualize the target and
weigh the risk
now for the first time you'll hear
directly from a team member who built
the bin laden compound the united states
has conducted an operation that killed
osama bin laden months before the
successful raid by seal team 6
analysts zeroed in on this mysterious
compound in pakistan
i think it screamed you know something's
different vice admiral robert
sharp leads the national geospatial
intelligence agency
that makes maps and models for highly
classified missions
why was a physical model important to
the navy seals planning the raid
models like these are just incredibly
valuable
for an execution of operation of this
complexity
and importance this is a rare look
inside the secret spy agency workshop
where a team of four model makers
crafted this replica of osama bin
laden's hideout
one inch for every seven feet now for
the first time
one of them is speaking out he asked us
to shield his identity
does your family know what you do they
know that i build models
but they don't know what i build models
of it's a three-step process
first they map the boundaries then
create a computer design
before printing 3d parts the bin laden
model took
six weeks to build intel flowed from
eyes in the sky and spies on the ground
this compound stuck out for several
reasons it's about eight times larger
than surrounding compounds
other compounds they build right out to
the walls and you see this the house is
centered
that detail right there tells you this
person is very focused on their security
very focused on the security with high
walls to hide the six
foot four bin laden if you look at the
house itself
and the top floor this balcony area
there's a seven foot wall so nobody can
see the individual
the only glimpses in this garden where a
man walked for hours
earning the nickname the pacer did you
ever think about who lived there
we had discussions about who we thought
it might be
maybe a high value terror target we
always joke about
if if we're modeling your house then you
got something coming
their past targets fill this archive
from a cold war
soviet aircraft carrier to a panamanian
dictator
manuel noriega's beach house they even
modeled the moon
for the apollo astronauts to practice
landing
more than four decades later the daring
bin laden raid did not go to plan
after one of the helicopters was forced
into a controlled crash
the model helped them understand and
execute plan b
absolutely it gave the navy seals a
sense
that they had been here before just like
in sports you try and visualize
every move that you're going to go
through
as the world cheered the al-qaeda
leader's death the seals got a message
to the model team
the navy seals passed along that they
were able to
count their footsteps based off of the
model you helped keep the navy seals
safe that night yeah that's how i look
at
projects like this tonight we give
thanks to the countless intelligence and
counterterrorism professionals
justice has been done the model maker we
spoke with said he didn't put it all
together until he saw the breaking news
coverage of the raid on tv
and he recognized one of the walls from
the replica he built
and on this 9 11 anniversary anthony
everyone we spoke to talked about
honoring the families
and their deep pride supporting the
mission
catherine thank you what an amazing
story that is i have to admit i had no
idea that the
national geospatial intelligence agency
even
existed but thank goodness it does yeah
job well done
yeah i also love the the uh how they
quarantine the information so the model
maker didn't realize what the model was
for until he saw the wall on tv except
he had the joke he said we have that
if if we're modeling your house then you
have some yeah
i wrote that down too where they talk
about a high value terror target but
what uh also is so amazing
that it's able to be kept secret yeah
in the age where everything is released
that they were able to because that
night was very hairy
you go back and really look and see what
happened you can imagine how valuable
seeing that model was all those seals
nicely done thank you catherine